ladies and gentlemen my name is ryan
right and my name is Jerry welcome to
the movie buff podcast today's episode
we are going to be talking okay here's
how we really talk okay another sound
I'm putting on our radio yes today on
105 we're gonna please all these them
yeah there was no [ __ ] way in hell we
were going to talk like that the whole
damn time that would be a feat that
would be impressive all right so what
today we're going to be talking about
our upcoming movies we're just going to
go through the whole list that we have
here from comingsoon.net no not a porn
site hahahahaha bet you didn't see that
one coming haha but she didn't see that
one coming too I did No ok it's like a
it's like a parody movie joke yeah it's
probably cuz we just saw the trailer for
scary movie 5 and a haunted house yeah
yeah we did which both look this same
and yet equally horrible you know what
you know though I'm less upset I'll tell
you the less upset it scary movie 5
because there are a couple other scenes
at least like the haunted house trailer
is just like oh hey obvious joke oh hey
I'll video I could write this without
writing it in my sleep like it looks
like somebody I like Marlon Wayans a lot
but oh like even dance flick was alright
but this looks Freiburg seltzer man my
biggest complaint though is with scary
movie 5 this is a sequel that it's weird
I always kind of won't want even though
they always end up disappointing me you
know what I mean yeah well see this
because the trailers the scary movie was
like no matter how bad the installments
are you know it's like at least the
Zucker brothers who did the three to
four at least they bothered to write a
joke now and then or at least they do
their work play or they make a pun you
know I saw a face did it have a nose
like at least that's a joke you know
it's not just someone getting smashed by
a cow that fell out of this guy and
going look it's YouTube because we know
what that is like it's at least a joke
at least it may not be a good one but
it's a joke yeah that's true that's true
but the scary movie trailers always gave
me hope but this scary movie 5
trailer doesn't give me any hope at all
neither of these trailers yeah give me
hope but a haunted house gives me less
hope because I'm like oh maybe it's
because I care more like I like Marlon
Wayans like I said maybe it's because
I'm like oh I wanted you to make me
happy and and you look like you're doing
something even worse like yeah I thought
like oh he's gonna make a comeback I
thought of eight I thought it was nice I
thought it was gonna be something like
man these [ __ ] have been trying to
make scary movies without us for so long
right I'm gonna show y'all how it's done
yeah like do dance flick was pretty
funny and they did those jokes again so
I was like okay yeah Marlon Wayans let's
do this i'm still down with dance flick
is pretty funny in comparison to what we
usually get from parody movies yeah well
cuz we're used to freiburg and seltzer
now and all their d don't write jokes so
yeah problem for those you don't know
those guys are the ones who've done
movies like epic movie meet the Spartans
date movie yeah a disaster move they do
really really horrible films and all the
joke I'm not even exaggerating the joke
is literally it's Paris Hilton and then
we all go I know what that is and she
doesn't belong there yeah what happens
when you put Paris Hilton in Greece
exactly yeah except again except nothing
happens yeah oh it's like one of the
main characters goes look it's thing you
know about and then we're supposed to
laugh at it yeah dance flick it was like
at least do such as like Shawn Wayans
comes he's like I'm here to pick up my
son he picks him up and he puts it right
back down and leaves oh yeah I'm every
cracking and validly is definitely that
was a hilarious moment I was a really
funny moment yeah that crack me up and
in a haunted house just doesn't like
Marlins my one of my favorite Wayans
brothers yeah collect all five all right
guys so what we're gonna do is we're
going to go through this list starting
off with what just got released this
weekend and that you're about to go see
in a little bit this is perfect excited
for his you're gonna start off the year
so you're about to go see this film
Texas Chainsaw 3x
is chainsaw I'm a little worried I'm not
gonna lie I don't know [ __ ] about this
movie I really just don't seem to be
interested in it you know because it
doesn't seem like there's anything there
that's compelling to me because the
first Texas Chainsaw Massacre I really
enjoyed a lot don't want Jess 70s or the
2,000 the one with Jessica Biel the
remake is solid and somebody pointed
this out to me the other day actually is
that that's it's one of it came at a
time in sort of the scream era where
everyone was kind of smart assy and
stuff and it's like it is it is kind of
a slasher where people are authentically
terrified and I always point this guy on
jonathan tucker in that movie look this
guy up he's in a hundred girls huh
jonathan tucker is the guy with the
curly hair on the glass is like he sells
the [ __ ] out of that yeah I mean I saw
that movie when it first came out and I
was probably in like eighth or ninth
grade when I when I saw that and I
remember it terrified me so much and not
just weekend that's like kind of the
audience are looking for that yeah is
peep is kids who are gonna sneak into
the theater kids who are old enough to
go to the theater yeah and I was all
rating means nothing yeah kids are gonna
see it so I saw it before I was 17 and
I'm part of the target market at that
point and I'd honestly terrified the
[ __ ] out of me yeah I really dig it I
you know it's it's different from the
original one and it's you know it's
well-made it's grimy it's creepy liking
alden just the messed-up hick people and
I didn't really like the prequel they
had but it still looked cool you know
see the thing is that those I don't know
how the new one is with those movies at
least like I k for whatever you can
knock them on production design is not
one of them because like they always
look good and they always have a eerie
backwoods vibe that I enjoy yeah and you
know r lee ermey is constantly stealing
the scenes so well according to with
like box office mojo you know Texas
Chainsaw is doing pretty well yeah well
I mean it's got a building it was it's
one of those things you don't even have
to have seen a Texas Chain Saw movie to
know who Leatherface is and what you
know the general vibe is
and so the new one is supposed to be but
there's nothing that seems like they're
trying anything special there than 3d
well they kind of are see here's the
thing obviously I haven't seen it yet
but they're calling this the true sequel
to the original 1970s texas chainsaw
massacre which there already is one
which is Texas Chainsaw Massacre to
which is the movie that made bill
moseley famous you guys probably know
from The Devil's Rejects at least but
this movie goes screw all those sequels
this is the actual sequel so it's
basically saying none of that should
happen this is what happened ok um and
well that sounds pretty cool actually my
opinion just totally changed right there
that sounds awesome i should have found
out just the exact plot detail yeah yeah
so it's an Emmy tobe hooper who directed
the first one and the second one has
even said this is the actual sequel okay
you know that's that's sort of what the
thing is um okay that sounds pretty cool
maybe i'll check that out actually yeah
and you know i don't know what to think
i'm a little worried because a lot of
the feedback has of azure road yeah but
I'm I'm cautiously optimistic I've heard
some weird stuff about it so it'll be an
experience for sure moving on we already
covered haunted house pretty much how
about this January 11th gangster squad
gangster squad I am so excited for this
[ __ ] movie I can all wait just like
oh my favorite not my favorite but well
one of them is my favorite Ryan god I
know yeah but you know to see like Josh
brother just if I just heard Josh Brolin
and Ryan Gosling are in a movie together
I wanted in psyched about that I don't
even think you you necessarily need to
it's like the the cast you just hear
those guys aren't in and each one your
interest goes up just a little bit even
if you don't love those guys you like
really like Ryan Gosling Josh Brolin
sean penn emma stone like all those
people are together and what i love
about it is it looks like such a
different take on what they would do
with a movie that takes place at that
time you know you get movies like more
like public enemies that go for more of
this raw
deal this one went all stylish and it
looks [ __ ] amazing because he got
great actors in a super stylish movie
you got to academy award-nominated
actors you got Sean Penn who looks a
little goofy buddies huh but it still
he's uh he's an academy award-winning
actor and then you got you know Giovanni
Ribisi don't oh my god I'm a key element
Emma sounds great to always watch you
know and they were great chemistry in a
crazy stupid love so I'm excited to see
Ryan Gosling and then pair up again no
yeah no I was excited I haven't actually
seen a trailer since last year so oh
dude I'm going in a little bit of fresh
um I'm not gonna lie to you I am worried
about this movie because I know they've
had to to take out scenes and recut it
and stuff because of you know recent
tragedies and things and then it got
pushed to january so I'm a little
worried for I'm a little worried that
that perhaps just poor just unlucky
circumstance may affect the movie but
nevertheless you know I am looking
forward to it I hope it's good the
trailer to me just promise me exactly
what I hoped when I read the synopsis
for it yeah see I don't know the problem
for me nowadays I don't know what to do
with trailers anymore because when i see
a good trailer I'm automatically freaked
out that it's not gonna be good movie
yeah and then if I see a bad trailer
that I'm just like well maybe it's a bad
trailer because like a couple years ago
we had all these movies where the good
trailers were the bad movies and the bad
shows like it like x-men origins
wolverine and premier salvation that
outpatient looks so good from the
trailer and that Ella told you this like
that trailer still convinces me that it
could be a good movie like I see that
Raylan I'm like I know there's a cut out
here that works like I remember when
they first cast Christian Bale at room
was like come on Christian woody it what
are you doing and then they saw the
trailer and he's like oh he elevates the
film
a real food Oh with a great [ __ ]
actor behind it you watch it and you're
like what the [ __ ] are you doing
Christian Bale what no stop stop stop
this is a bad acting Christian please
that movie cross them off my list of
favorite actors just because he let me
down to that much would i watch that
really yeah has he regained I've seen
he's still those great movies like the
fighter and he can still totally deliver
my favorite performance of him in all
the Batman series in the not the Batman
series de batman dark knight trilogy was
the dark knight rises out of all the
performances of him being Batman and he
still impresses me but that film still
hurts my feelings do that yeah I've
largely forgotten about it no I really
think about it but let's see January
18th oh we got two movies coming out
yeah yeah we got broken love and officer
down ya supa we got broken city we got
broken city and the last time Todd and
Mama yeah I garibo del Toro producing it
which which I found out wasn't entry
into the horror nights film festival oh
really it's a foreign entry they've
actually been playing on youtube if you
some videos you look up they actually
have been playing this short as the pre
video ad uh-huh that sure is pretty
creepy whoa the shorts pretty unsettling
it's simple but it's got check that out
yeah I saw the trailer for that it's
good to [ __ ] out of me i forgot about i
saw when i saw paranormal activity 4 and
i watched that because i get spooked by
like that's I grew up in my Catholic
upbringing okay you know where you
really hear a lot about like where
you're you know exorcism yeah crazy
demonic [ __ ] happening so when I saw the
trailer i get i got really spooked by a
man and most trailer most horror movie
trailers don't get to me that much yeah
yeah i'm i'm cautiously optimistic about
this one too i was a january really Jane
the thing is that I'm trying to to keep
that out of my mind because a last year
was kind of a year where what any one of
my favorite movies of 2012 was a January
least it was one of the first movies I
saw and there were a lot of movies like
limitless and and 21 Jump Street those
came out towards the beginning of the
year and people were like oh these were
actually good oh yeah I remember that so
I'm trying to cool down on the January
like brow meetings and like I said you
know the great was fantastic to me but
I'm hoping Mama's gonna have a little
afraid just because the stuff Gil mother
Toro presents is not always as good as
the stuff he directs himself it's like
hear about or the director I still do
let's do it and then it's always a
decent movie at least yeah it's sure
like i like the orphanage and and don't
be afraid of the dark was was ok once I
got past behind it's a decent to film
yeah yeah they're decent so I'm hoping
like don't be afraid of the dark is
certainly not a great film it was I was
let down it was a lead on someone
because because of all those stories
about it's so scary and had to be rated
R like but at the end of the day it's
still better than a lot of the other
horror movies we get yeah and I think
mama can be one of those fellows oh just
a funny title than me but let's move on
to like the last stand with
Schwarzenegger Ahnold he's back you know
but he's old yeah but he's also back
yeah he's old he's part of the old gang
of action carrots there's like this
necklace genre it's like this new
category of like they got Bruce Willis
Sylvester Stallone Schwarzenegger always
playing old people who can still kick
ass and everyone talks about how they're
old and then references to [ __ ] they
used to say when they were younger it's
it's a zoo sub-genre of a old guy who's
too old to maybe be doing this but he's
still kicking ass and everyone's giving
[ __ ] for being old you know it's so
weird is like the people you're least
excited for when you hear about the
expendables is like Jason Statham and
jelly yeah the ones who are not that
other ones who are you don't have to
play old people Yeah right but freaking
like you hear about Schwarzenegger and
stuff you get excited about it and I'm
actually kind of interested in watching
this just because it looks like such a
bad movie
yeah it looks like a great bad time like
what if the action ends up being a lot
of fun yeah you want to go with your
friend who's really big into like those
those late eighties early nineties like
yeah I saw a ton of Arnold movie yeah
like you want to go on in a house packed
with those people who are just there to
watch Arnold kick some asses and listen
to johnny Knoxville wisecracks like yeah
I'm excited for johnny Knoxville to
reprise his role from walking tall I
like Daddy document isn't you know yeah
isn't theirs then and then there's a
broken city this broken city that's
coming out it looks like it was shot
like a low-budget film in a way doesn't
it well yeah it has that almost video
not video quality but it has a sort of
like which is surprisingly a hot look
for a film to have mark wahlberg and
Russell Crowe youth you wouldn't imagine
like that kind of quality yeah I mean I
get the camera I can see it as a choice
though for the call really type of grit
they're going for and especially since
it's like they're a big part of the
story element seems to be surveillance
you can kind of tell that I kind of get
it as a choice if it's a choice broken
city Catherine said well I'm excited I'm
excited to watch it just because I love
the idea of Mark Wahlberg and Russell
Crowe bring being in a movie together
yeah you know Mark Wahlberg there's a
time where I didn't like Mark Wahlberg
but then there's then suddenly something
happened where he just shifted into like
one of the people i'd love to watch the
most well yeah cuz he's one of those
guys he's kind of like he's kind of like
Will Smith in the sense that he's one of
those guys who can now do anything yeah
and be super gritty in serious or he can
be really funny / he can go do this like
soft quiet thing like he's sort of doing
it all right now the thing is he's
always been confident I think it's why
people have always liked him no matter
why mar oh the mics on and because
because he's kind of like Channing Tatum
in a way because Channing Tatum was like
a shitty [ __ ] act Channing Tatum ha I
mean don't get me wrong I love Mark
Wahlberg in like Boogie Nights I thought
he was amazing fantastic in it and I was
made that and he was fantastic in it but
he's done a lot of movies as I hands
like Channing Tatum you know everyone
knew him as being just a pretty boy like
just a bad actor yeah just a really bad
at mouth pretty boy was it expect well
if you move yeah and the thing was
though he always seemed to believe he
was doing a good job I think he that's
how confident he looked and I think Mark
Wahlberg had the same thing going on but
Channing Tatum we know with 21 Jump
Street in Magic Mike he's really been
getting a lot of respect lately this is
true and now i'm looking at mark
wahlberg and thinking about he's kind of
like the same way cooler well and Mark
Wahlberg you know he came out of Marky
Mark and the Funky Bunch you know like
he was doing his hip hop pop star thing
and then you know he came out of that to
be to be an actor he has had that kind
of interesting progression over time
from being you know six pack rapping guy
to relax and now let's see January 25th
hands of and gretel witch hunt toes uh
with Jeremy Renner the amazing actor
who's setting out to be an action star
instead there's some reason I thought
you were going to say Jeremy Renner d
amazing spider-man but Jeremy Renner
he's pretty cool still yeah I think
that's what's kind of funny about him is
she's this really talented actor but he
seems to be going after the action movie
audience yeah or or people are just
offering him amazing action roles like
hey you want to be the Avengers buddy
yeah they did Hank come here hey hey
take over born for us hey hey why don't
you want to start with Tom Cruise in the
next mission impossible film yeah come
on well it'll be fun he's just getting
all these great films I know he's doing
a bank robbery movie and I I think
nobody's just gonna rob a bank oh yeah
I'm bank was like would you please rob
us I think it would bring a lot more
business and now he's doing Hansel and
Gretel witch hunters which I have not
seen a trailer for yet oh it looks like
a lot of fun a lot of fun that's what
I've heard
I've heard that it kind of has that
Lincoln vampire like it looks like just
a bad vibe yeah it looks more but it
looks like it knows what it wants to be
okay and just a damn badass fun time
that's the thing i had that was wrong
with Lincoln look like it didn't really
know what I wanted to be this film I
think really does know what it wants to
be the other thing though on january
25th I am really excited about it's
already out on video on demand but i
really want to see john dies at the end
which is a don coscarelli new movie and
he did like phantasm and bubba hotep and
oh wow yeah he's a he's a reasonable
reasonably prolific director and this
movie look I've heard it's crazy and
strange and out there and trippy and
really cool so I'm I'm very excited to
finally get to check that out on the big
screen hopefully well Paul Giamatti's in
it yeah oh wow it's a horror sci-fi
movie yeah interesting gonna check that
[ __ ] out yeah check that [ __ ] a lot of
movies we gotta watch this this you know
it's you know what's interesting about
January like injecting usually January's
known as a year where all the [ __ ] comes
out yeah it's what is the graveyard
furniture dolly what just takes a big
dump and just goes well [ __ ] yeah it's
the part of the point of the year or
they're like well we made these so I
guess you have to watch that but there's
a lot of movies that are actually coming
out this month like them genuinely
interested in that it could be possible
I don't know wanna say Oscar contenders
but I think gangster squad has some
Oscar potential maybe I don't get I
don't quite pull an Oscar vibe from that
just because the kind of movie I
remember the trailers I could see it was
like cinematography or for art design or
perhaps design yeah perhaps I mean I
feel like it's it's almost 22 stylized
into grunged up to be Oscar Oscar
conditions like that type of movie for
Oscar contention I think of like LA
confidential and it doesn't give me an
LA confidential vibe really yeah that's
true um but I think it could definitely
again like
on the cruise side yeah I thought Tom
Cruise side the the crew side yeah no
time kruseman's man yeah but I think it
still has potential for other
nominations maybe not necessarily do
with the story and plot I think it'll be
saw production design I or at least I
hope I hope it's good I kind of get a
vibe like it'll at least be solid but I
know Hansel and Gretel supposed to come
out last year and so was and so is a
gangster and to see a movie with uh you
know Russell Crowe and mark wahlberg and
a movie together and Catherine
zeta-jones yeah yeah all three of them
going to move together coming out in
January like that's pretty exciting man
yeah so for this looks like a good
January month in this other movie is
comes on january 25th is movie 43 I saw
the trailer for that Adam crap I don't
even know how does it look I kind of
want to avoid a trailer because i'm
afraid the trailer will let me down
because i'm very excited about this huge
[ __ ] cast um here's what i'll say
about the trailer bid I don't really
know if the trailer has any reflection
on the movie whatsoever because I was
constantly the way the trailer is
constructed I was constantly sitting
there going wait what is going on
because there it's like because they
keep jumping back and forth between
these different scenes I'm like wait a
minute those people are in it and and
these guys are in it and and and she's
in it and he's in it and wait hold on a
second I think it's a sketch comedy
movie yeah it is I just I hadn't heard a
thing about it until I saw the trailer
and the trailer what I was like what I
kind of want to see this but what on
earth did I just see well let's just
name off some of the big ones here
Elizabeth Banks Kristen Bell Halle Berry
kate bosworth st / hillman gerard butler
common uh Karen colca oh yeah I reckon
Josh Duhamel chip or josh duhamel I
think I've heard it said his dude I've
heard him say do email Anna Faris
Richard Gere Terrence Howard Oh John
Hodgman I lived on Hugh Jackman Greg
Kinnear johnny Knoxville Justin Long
Stephen Merchant Chrisman's plus made me
laugh in the trailer i don't really
laugh at
trailers very often and he made me laugh
so Chloe grace Moretz who is very pretty
and will be even hotter when she's 18
she was in that same Dennis Quaid Chris
Pratt liev schreiber i would say leave
liev schreiber alone yeah his name is
named like everyone says different I've
heard a lot of people say live leave
Liev like I don't know seann william
scott emma stone Jason Sudeikis Sadako's
Sudeikis Sudeikis good Emma Thurman Nami
wats Kate Winslet yeah that was the big
like that one threw me off i was like
Caitlyn's lesson like what's gonna
happen she's gonna get naked it's
important yeah I mean it's rated R for a
graphic nudity strong for race of crude
and sexual content i'm assuming that
comes with the graphic nudity I don't
know actually because uh there's one
sketch that they hint at that could be
responsible for that that is a little
out there why won't get too much into
detail I won't spoil it but yeah there's
a I can see graphic nudity coming from a
lot of different places not just people
making it well I'm excited for that
movie too there's a lot of movies that
are coming out man Wow too many two
moons stop Swift the movie stop making
movie we wanted a talking well that's it
for January we'll be back for februari
in a month one month to give you guys
that's how time works our anticipation
review yeah yeah it's gonna be a fun
time Jerry I hope you have a good time I
did have a good time this was fun and I
said I hope you do have a good time oh
thank you responded positively at the
end of the day so thank you I have a
good time doing what watching texas
chainsaw tonight as you start off your
january oh that's right yeah well yeah
well yeah i don't know what happened
there yeah no no I'm excited this is
gonna be good i'm gonna hopefully i'll
come back out of my zero dark thirty
hole with some texts yes I action scrub
the scrub the palate a little bit scrub
one violent type of movie
whoa there's kind of like harsh yeah
unsettling real is over thank God fun
violence yeah yeah exactly thank you
thank god this is at least
hyper-stylized I can watch people died
feel okay about yeah all right guys well
that's it for January will be back in
one month for februari thank you for
listening to Ryan ride and Jerry on the
movie buff show did it did it dude yay
it's pretty sick